fucking people yes indeed for those who
don't know I have a particular hate for
the cartoon series Doug not because the
show itself is an ungodly boring waste
of time though that certainly doesn't
help but more than know growing up with
the name Doug was constantly tortured by
the fact that the show was about a wimpy
unpopular dork a doofus and
coincidentally shared the same name just
hearing the theme music alone seems to
be causing an impressive tumor in my
brain that I had decided to name
porkchop I look forward to when it
finally finishes me off and I never have
to listen to that song again but I
digress
what's Disney took over and start
running the show on ABC as opposed to
Nickelodeon fans were outraged because
you know the original was such a classic
so once Disney asked the loyal fans if
they would like to see a motion picture
based on the astounding epic hero people
all over the world proudly replied then
and the movie was made and we're here to
look at it today
why because you got damn hey hey fucking
people by popular demand let's take a
look at Doug's first movie first of all
I have to point out that this title is
pretty pompous it's if to indicate that
there's no doubt that our film is going
to be so popular that of course it's
going to warrant a sequel but unlike
Pokemon the first movie where they knew
the sequels were already made this one
was just on its own and when to know it
the film didn't make enough money to
know Danny see
and that must be bad because this is
fucking Disney the sequel generating
monsters they have the balls to take
classic fairy tales and say hey what did
ever happen after happily ever after
well you can find out and Cinderella for
filing royal taxes but I digress the
film opens in the 90s but for some
reason people act like it's the 50s as
being told by the 70s as we see school
bully Roger not voiced by Billy West buy
your torches and pitchforks hear who's
preparing to pull off another prank on
Doug and his friends Skeeter but don't
you think this is kind of mean it's
unhealthy for me to bottle up my natural
job like spontaneity I guess they're
really hoping they're afraid of paper
mache Chinese dragons very funny you
guys hardy har well you had your fun
okay there's no gourd but there is
something just as equally terrifying the
opening credits roll it porkchop kyon
here comes the opening theme
you mean they change the opening theme
that's me
oh it's bland it's forgettable it sounds
like nothing I would ever remember in
recent history but hey so is the fucking
show it's absolutely perfect
rest in hell you goddamn theme but man
army of Devil's sinking tonight fiery
death oh that's good Oh after we just
assumed Skeeter got away from the
monster
Doug informs us that the one thing
that's on everybody's mind that means at
school people have just one thing on
their minds is it romantic a Valentine's
dance I'll be right home Oh Valentine's
Valentines who the hell talks about it
dance this much I mean the girls I can
understand but the boys really somehow
this doesn't seem particularly realistic
hey Bobby good job on that last shot oh
you know it's these new Air Jordans
adults don't do anything goes through
they can make you reach the nerd ease my
body you've been watching too many come
here seriously is nobody thinking about
the dance
so Doug decides he wants to ask out the
sweetheart he's always too nervous to
approach the girl next door with
jaundice Patti mayonnaise I knew I had
to find a way to make this dance really
perfect the student council supposed to
pick two people to coordinate the dance
but nobody signed up whoever we get is
gonna have to work day and night to get
ready day and night
right pay close attention miss
mayonnaise oh hi totally pointless
fantasy sequence we hit him right in the
middle with a big hot shake Miraval bang
Oh Doug you're so damn scary uh I can
understand having a fantasy dreaming
about working with her but why is a
reward to general I mean it's just so
random
don't fantasies have to have some sort
of logical reasoning behind them hmm one
of these days I like to do a crossover
with Nash you are weird do you really
think I'd be good at organizing a dance
I've never done anything like that I
think you'd be great at whatever you
wanted to do Patti especially me not
much competition so both Doug and Patti
sign on for the dance committee but only
Patti gets chosen the other position
goes to a guy named guy guy Graham
upperclassmen heads up dinky dance bad
it turns out guy joined the committee to
get fresh with Patti - well dad you
understand dad has real accomplishments
eat and he spends with my daddy's fine
young man but for the moment even bigger
news seems to have fallen into their lap
some monster
laughter they dissolve to one second
later Doug gets excited about the
possibilities a picture of a foot can
bring when the biggest thing ever
happens biggest thing ever
Doug imagines himself a superhero as the
script narrating now what's going on
that night Quailman rendezvous with a
certain young woman Oh
Quailman Jesus what is the point of
these fantasies yes he placed the
character on the show but what does that
have to do with what's going on right
now looks like an uninvited guest is
trying to crash the party quaildog
it's like if scrubs and Family Guy Joe
call they're pointless cutaway jokes and
turn into some sort of horrible hybrid
of wasted time
well ma'am and a super pal quaildog and
not only that this fantasy goes on for a
while almost as if we went into a
totally different movie if only I was a
lucky whoa ah and the lord of the ball
guy care to dance
yeah grab my balls curious I'm not
kidding this fantasy goes on for like
four minutes which in Disney animated
years is like 20 well dog shows the
high-powered disco light to the eyes of
the monster momentarily disorienting the
reptilian rowdy I don't even get it does
don't just black out for a while Lau's
friends just look at him awkwardly so
Doug what do you think about the picture
dog I miss you when you do this
why do you go where I can't follow
meanwhile Roger and his henchmen because
all school bullies have Benjamin in
cartoons put together a plan to find the
monster they discover the other night
there is only one thing that can save us
from certain destruction I present to
you Robo Roger note the pincer claws and
x-ray eyes I join myself down here for
scale money is no object okay so all
reality connecting to what children do
in high school has totally been removed
but I guess that's what I'd expect in a
world where everybody looks like a dr.
Seuss mutant look guy got mr. Bluff to
give us money to have the dance at MU
are you ready for this funky town okay I
swear to gosh she said Bucky town you
know it's gonna be an orgy theme but
they Bazooka Joe me tonight in Paris but
little do they know that the monster
from the other night follow them home
till they take the Paranormal Activity
approach in that they never call the
cops and try to fight off the scariness
themselves
Buffy find out that the monster isn't
scary at all I dare even call him a
complete letdown can't believe that I
tried to eat her a Melville he looked he
thinks it's his name you like that name
Herman Melville hmm ok monster from now
on your name is Herman Melville
whoo I feel disgrace somehow so they go
to their friend mr. dink
to tell him all about the monster and to
be fair he does manage to deliver the
only funny scene in the movie virtual
reality it's like we're standing right
in your living room exactly everything
is white where he is in real life it's
exactly like being here only much more
special sort of like watching Doug on
the big screen when you could be
watching it at home for free mr. Duke me
Herman Melville the monster of Lucky
paprika so they let the Mara know about
their discovery and I guess because
she's in politics her first reaction is
to cover it up you mean to tell me that
he came out of that polluted lake but
hang up dear now if we call the
newspaper owned by bluff go and tell
them we've got a story that bill Bluff
is a polluter someone will kill the
story and let's just say it won't be
good for Herman either being the mayor
it's not like I have any possible power
to fix this problem at all so I guess
we're stuck get it cool get a clue you
moron get a clue what she does decide to
hold a press conference the next day to
show the monster on her terms
so Doug tells patty about what's going
on right in front of guy who's good
friends with mr. Bluff we have proof mr.
Bluffs polluting the lake I wouldn't go
around saying stuff you can't prove well
I got proof come on dumbass are you in
fact if you look up demands in the
dictionary you'll find a picture of
let's Tempe you in there well you better
watch yourself mr. Bluff got us into
funky town to have a disc stop sing
fucking town it's a g-rated flick where
to pronounce your ends you'll see you
tomorrow
it's
to be big big big big news but when the
day of the big news conference arrives
Doug thinks there's something suspicious
about all the reporters gee what could
have given him that idea maybe because
they're all dressed like Robert Stack
flashers sorry
always wanted to do that on TV you're a
waste of thought so to save the monster
Doug totally bails on the news
conference something's not right
I think we made a big mistake I knew it
sea monsters right I can't believe it I
had no idea
I say we judge strictly by how it looks
and in no way questioned motivation or
character so after they find out that
the reporters did indeed work for mr.
Bluff and that it was just a plan to
capture the monster the mayor's plan is
going to be a half bluff arrested beat
document all that she can through video
and eyewitnesses that the monster is
real or see have some of buds famous
leftover meat loaf now what do you say
we have some of buds famous leftover
meat loaf
now you're talking about let's go boy am
i alors tell me I mom art none of this
makes any goddamn says I must be on Mars
I mean this is as logical as Roger and
his friends actually making that giant
robot they were talking about
Oh what you never did this in high
school I did it all the time right after
I made the honor roll in mobile studies
then you look at my plan it's supposed
to be this big compared to me but it's
okay
they have a shrinking ray to make him
the scale they wanted um hey here's an
idea instead of calling a news
conference about a sea monster um why
don't you call the news conference about
a bunch of high schoolers I made a
fucking shrinking ray or a giant fucking
robot don't you think that should get
some attention
don't you think instead of just
shrugging comedic lis these kids should
get a Nobel Prize for changing the world
of science as we fuckin know it what's
wrong with you jelly bean colored
Simpson rejects fucking people but I
digress
things believe it or not get even
weirder as Rogers robot turns into a
motherly housemate a sort of Julia Child
bot if you will now what change out of
that beastly outfit and into something
more presentable
okay this idea could be salvageable if
she gets in a bloody death match with
Rosie from the Jetsons I don't know how
they fit in but trust me they couldn't
make it any worse so because we're not
done ripping off every G movie cliche
known to cinema we now get the bit where
they disguise the creature as a person
and of course everybody Falls for it
what's your name it's Herman oh no 90 ah
what a beautiful name Herman I knew 90
Hey you know what this is really stupid
wait a minute what okay all right I can
believe the boys getting excited for the
dance
I can believe them they're not using her
powers at all to prove with
earth-shattering discovery
I can believe high schoolers can build a
giant robot and a shrinking ray and have
none of that get any media attention but
if you expect me to believe that any
high school girl high school girl mind
you will look at this deformed demon
think he's a female student and actually
verbally acknowledge that she's cute you
are on math I me my god do you have any
idea how the teenage female mind works
they will pick apart anything that is
not stylized perfection this is the
species that's turning this into a
cultural phenomenon they will criticize
thighs thighs for God's sake and you're
seriously telling me they would call
this beauty show genocide tell you what
you are fired from breathing please pack
up your desk and kindly leave yeah but I
got good Doug I'm not gonna stand here
be lied to
I'm not blind you know I know you're
really spending your time with that
Hermoine girl you've been hanging around
with all day diary made a Hogwarts jokes
I'll just let this one go come on Patti
she's not even a girl I know you think I
must be done because I believed all that
mobster stuff before but I hope you
don't think I'm that gullible guy what
do you think that's that really Doug
you're trying to take this girl so later
that night block captures the creature
and they take him away trying to think
of something to do Doug comes across the
story that guy is writing for the school
paper
on the screen next week's Weekly Beebe
Muenster destroyed bill bluff a hero
we're too late
Herman's dead wait you just said it was
next week obviously he wrote it ahead of
time before it happened
they killed Herman this stinks yeah but
it's next week's paper the horrible
monster was blasted into smithereens
thus saving the dance organized by cool
upperclassman guy Graham next week spray
per night of fun turns into night of
terror
didn't you see Tomorrow Never Dies in
the James Bond stain way to fuck off
wait that's the dance isn't until
tonight
of course guy wanted to make sure this
was in next week's paper you mean when I
said was next week's paper it was
actually next week's paper
oh god must have known I'd be stupid
enough to do whatever it is my brain
just did there so the night of the dance
comes and nobody seems to question why
security has been up to Nazi level
extremes we're still allowed to see so
many of you lovely people here tonight
but especially like
you all enjoy the show they managed to
find the monster and dress up the fembot
to go in posing is it
whoa pretty harsh on the robot there
aren't you guys take this dough I can't
believe I'm needlessly cruel they're
being to this thing
so they return the monster to the water
and blood has to explain himself may a
dink fail I think you should discuss
your pollution problems with me oh yes
of call sammlung certainly and just like
most elected officials they come into
the problem too late do absolutely
nothing to solve it and yet somehow they
take all the credit what it finally
works out you elected them folks but the
monster comes back one more time to say
goodbye after the people have left I
forgot I brought you something remember
this Herman Melville's works yes he
writes about a monster in the water who
people tried to hunt down and kill but
don't worry though he'll enjoy the
ending
so he goes back into the water and we
get to see our favorite character one
more time before the film ends no no not
that puke stain oh my god I feel so
sorry for this thing how is it you know
cast of characters this big and
literally this colorful the only one I
feel any amount of emotion for is the
lifeless robot it's actually kind of
hard to watch
razza children go give him his coat
robot you have America on your side
Patti and I danced on the dock under the
moon for quite some time I wouldn't have
minded if it had gone on forever
I'll just assume that's a fart we're
ending on and call the film quits
so that was Doug's first movie aren't
you so glad they brought that to the big
screen I mean what was even the purpose
nothing about it streamed cinema so why
do they even make it as you probably
guess it suffers from the same problem
that the show suffers from it's bland
and boring I hate this movie I hate this
show I need everything having to do with
it and thank God this is the last thing
I ever had to review having to deal with
it because I swear if I hear that song
one more time I don't know what's gonna
happen not a nostalgic break I remember
it fucking people
Roger Rosen
it's con time from November 11 to
November 13th I'm gonna be returning to
shadowkhan in Tampa Florida also in
November from the 18th to the 20th I'm
gonna be a collision con which is in
pheasant run sync charm rap my home
state of Ella's go there and I will
break